we're very lucky to
- here to talk to us about genetics abba
started here got our undergraduate
degree at yale then because really one
Ivy League school isn't enough got her
MD and PhD at the University of
Pennsylvania came back here to train
with math state and has stayed on I was
a developmental behavioral pediatrician
but she also does excellent research in
the genetics of autism Baba is also a
good friend and one of the most honestly
scientifically enthusiastic people that
I encounter at yeah you have a
conversation with Ava and you feel like
it renews your faith in the scientific
method and that we're gonna figure these
questions out you feel like a first year
graduate student all over again
so Abba the floor is yours thing thanks
Jamie that was very generous so I'm
happy here to talk to you today about
something that's really fascinated me
for many years the genetics of autism
spectrum disorders I want to start off
with just some basic concepts in
genetics before we delve into autism
specifically so the nuclear compartment
in most of the cells of our body contain
our genetic material and this is
packaged as 23 pairs of chromosomes one
set of the pair being inherited
maternally and the other set being
inherited paternally and so the form of
this genetic material is in chromosomes
which is a very simplified diagram of a
chromosome so you can see there's a
central part there are two arms short
arms and long arms and so this
chromosome is made up of what you've no
I'm sure you're part of the DNA double
helix the DNA ladder and it does kind of
look like a letter there's these sides
and then the rungs are made up of what
are called nucleotides these chemicals
bases that pair up in a very specific
way and so stretches of DNA make up
genes which encode for proteins that
make up our bodies and it's the very
specific sequence of these bases or
nucleotides that is the genetic code
that codes for the sequence of amino
acids and the proteins that make up our
body alright so as I mentioned DNA is
housed in the nuclei
of ourselves it undergoes a process
called transcription in which the
genetic code is translated or excuse me
transcribed into molecules called
messenger RNA this has exported out into
the cytoplasm where it hooks up with
ribosomes approaching making machinery
and so again that genetic code the
sequence of nucleotides specifies the
sequence of amino acids that make up
this protein chain all right so when we
try to discover try to figure out what
DNA mutations might cause a disorder for
example autism we look for mutations so
one type of mutation consists of
sequence changes so again here's a
diagram of that DNA double helix and the
rungs are made up of those nucleotides
at an E thymine pair up guanine and
cytosine pair up specifically and then
sometimes maybe who knows why maybe it's
spontaneous maybe it's due to an
environmental trigger maybe some toxin
there might be a change so for example
this rung which is made up of an A and T
base pair changes into a C and G base
pair and so this could be completely
benign it might not affect the structure
or function of a protein at all or it
might cause differences between us for
example in hair color or height or
whatever or it could be very damaging so
it could affect the structure and
function of a protein maybe making it
dysfunctional or even non-functional and
that could be very consequential because
it could cause a disorder like autism so
here's some example of sequence
mutations this is an exam is sense
mutation where you again here have the
sequence of nucleotides along the DNA
ladder and so groups of three of these
nucleotides code for an amino acid so in
this example you have groups of C 80 the
initials for these nucleotides and these
code for an amino acid known as
histidine so again let's say we have a
spontaneous mutation or again may be
induced or inherited that turns this
nucleotide in a into a C and then the
histidine becomes a prolene so now you
have a different amino acid in the
middle of that protein change again it
might have no effect
could have a very damaging effect on the
structure and function of this protein
here's an example of what we usually
think of as very deleterious mutations
nonsense mutations because there are
some of these groups of three or
triplets of nucleotides that code for a
stop signal which tells the protein
making machinery that the amino at the
protein is done and you can stop making
that protein now so here in this example
a CAG triplet codes for an amino acid
notice glutamine let's say there's an
immune from a C to a T here but this t
AG actually codes for a stop codon and
if that occurs early on in the protein
or in the middle of a protein all of a
sudden you have an abnormally short
protein and that could be very damaging
but sequence variants are not the only
type of changes we look for we also look
for what are known as copy number
variants or CNB's so here's a simple
diagram showing examples of this here is
an example of a duplication so you have
a chromosome and let's say this material
and orange and green is duplicated so
again this might be benign or it could
be very damaging if you have genes in
this area that all of a sudden you have
an increased dose of and that could be
deleterious here's an example of a
deletion where you have a break on one
arm of the chromosome and this material
gets deleted and then even if the
chromosome comes back together again now
you're missing
maybe genes in that area that could be
very important that are expressed in the
brain so let's turn now to autism
specifically and what's the evidence for
a genetic basis and there are several
lines of evidence so one come from
family studies that look at sibling
recurrence risk so this is looking to
see how often do siblings in families
that already have a child with autism
how often do they also are diagnosed
with a autism spectrum disorders so our
study in 2011 showed that the risk is
almost 20% which is much higher than
what you would find in the general
population but one could argue well you
know siblings were up in the same
environment maybe it's environmental
maybe there's a shared environmental
risk that's leading to autism so
genetics researchers try to get around
that question by looking at twins so
they look at
monozygotic twins I've abbreviated that
is MZ and dizygotic twins so dizygotic
twins share about 50% of their genetic
information they're like any
brother-sister pair but monozygotic
twins are identical so they share 100%
of their genetic information so genetics
research have looked to see well how
often do MZ twins share a diagnosis
compared to DZ twins and it turns out
that monozygotic twins do share a
diagnosis more frequently than dizygotic
twins and that says that you know
they're growing up in the same
environment presumably so that there
must be something genetic going on
because they share a diagnosis more
frequently but what's important also no
doubt a note is that in these studies MZ
twins are not always concordance so if
you thought that autism was a hundred
percent genetic right you would expect
that identical twins would always share
a diagnosis and that's not the case so
there is something else going on and
many human geneticist in the field would
say they're probably some unknown
unclear environmental triggers as well
they were just don't know very well yet
another line of evidence for a genetic
basis is that there are about 10% of
cases that also have a genetic syndrome
that have been traced to very specific
mutations in specific genes so here are
some examples of autism related
syndromes so you've heard of probably
some of these before maybe the 15 cured
duplication Angelman syndrome 16 p11
fragile X syndrome for example we know
that fragile X is due to mutations in a
gene called fmr1 if you look at the
proportion of patients with fragile X
who have autism who meet criteria for
autism it's a big proportion about a
quarter of males 6% of females but if
you look at the reverse so the
proportion of patients who have been
diagnosed with autism who have the
syndrome it's actually quite small only
one to two percent so that tells you
that even though there's a significant
overlap between fragile X and not ISM
it's a rare cause of autism it doesn't
explain any big proportion of cases and
so and it's also not necessary or
sufficient another one for example is a
tuber sclerosis
we know tuber sclerosis is due to
mutations in the TSC one and TSC two
genes 20% of those patients meet
criteria for autism but to risk erosive
is only found about 1% of patients with
autism so again a rare cause of autism
but it's still important because it
gives us clues these kinds of overlaps
about what might be causing autism so
this is the bottom light slide really
bottom what I really want to get across
to you guys is that autism spectrum
disorders are complex with wide
phenotypic variability which you know
very well and there are multiple
ideological factors genetic and
environmental there's a great deal of
genetic heterogeneity and so really
there is no one gene for autism not even
a few the estimate is that there are
likely hundreds of genes for autism
which is very much a case also with
intellectual disability where it seems
that there are many genes that can lead
to intellectual disability so this slide
is a bit outdated but I wanted to just
show it to you to get across a point
that there are multiple chromosomal
regions across the genome that have been
implicated in autism so these are
diagrams of the human chromosomes and
you can see the tick marks on the left
point to areas chromosomal regions that
have been highlighted because of a
linkage study or an association study or
maybe published chromosomal abnormality
or some interesting gene there that's
been associated with autism and as you
can see they're really all over the
place so it's really hard to get a
handle on this like how do you study so
many different genes how do you figure
out what common pathway they might be
affecting or pathways so how do human
geneticists go about trying to identify
disease genes so there's two main
approaches one is positional the other
is functional and the positional
approach geneticists look at the entire
genome in an unbiased way so they're not
making any hypotheses about well I'm
gonna look at this region of the curve
the genome or this particular gene they
just look genome-wide and just ask where
are the mutations in individuals with
autism and then the functional method is
hypothesis driven so for example if you
have some theory about what causes
autism let's say you're convinced it's
the serotonin neurotransmitter system
then you'll hone in on just those genes
for example that encode the serotonin
receptors that transporters etc and then
so that's a very high
this is driven approach either way the
hope is that you'll find a list of
candidate genes and then really it takes
more follow-up work to confirm that
these really are disease genes so for
example geneticists will do mutation
screening of large cohorts so let's say
they have a family or two in which they
find an interesting mutation in a brain
express gene that seems it might be
associated with the phenotype they'll
look in larger groups of patients and
typically developing individuals to see
are there more mutations that they can
report on another very important thing
to do is functional analysis so you
might have a long list of genes and
mutations but you have to really figure
out okay these particular mutations how
do they affect the structure and
function of a protein do they really
cause damage and that's really important
to figure out because that's going to
give you clues to the pathophysiology of
the disorder all right so I'm going to
go through some of the techniques that
human geneticists use to try to find
candidate genes one is genome-wide
linkage studies so the bottom line here
is that we want to identify Llosa or
chromosomal regions that are inherited
by affected individuals more frequently
than you would expect by chance
so chromosomal regions chunks of
chromosomal regions are marked by DNA
polymorphisms such as snips you might
have heard of that term single
nucleotide polymorphisms those are
single bases that differ between people
and so what linkage studies look for is
how close if the closer a marker like a
snip is to a disease gene the more
likely you're gonna see close
segregation in other words the more
likely you're gonna see that snip or
snips traveling with the phenotype
through pedigrees through families
they're being inherit again because
they're so close together together so if
you pick up a paper on a linkage study
you'll see something called a LOD score
logarithm of the odds score and so this
represents the likelihood that a locus a
chromosomal region is linked to the
phenotype that you're studying so a lot
score of three indicates that there's a
thousand to one odds that the locus is
linked to the phenotype so in autism
specifically linkage Peaks have been
found on almost every chromosome so I've
distilled it down for you I think
there's at least 15 or more studies
genome-wide linkage studies in autism
and some of the highest LOD scores are
found in these chromosomal regions so a
lot score a 4.8 won which is quite
impressive on the long arm of chromosome
3 another one on the long arm of
chromosome two a couple of spots on
chromosome 17 but the problem has been
is that a lot of these studies don't
confirm each other they find different
sets of linkage Peaks so how do you get
a handle on that one thing that human
geneticist have tried to do is something
called stratification of their subject
so instead of taking all their subjects
they'll take a subset that are maybe
more phenotypically homogenius thinking
that maybe they'll find a common genetic
mechanism so a group I'm a while ago now
looked at 91 total families affected by
autism and they did a genome-wide
linkage scan so they had a number of
these markers all throughout the genome
and did this statistical analysis and
calculated a lot score which is not
quite impressive about two on the long
arm of chromosome 17 so in in complex
disorders such as autism a lot score of
3 points about 3.6 is considered
significant so this was not significant
but what they did next was interesting
so they took a subset of their families
in which the affected child was always a
male and then repeated the analysis and
found that their LOD score on the same
region more than doubled so this doesn't
mean that they found a gene that
explains all of autism it means that
maybe they found a gene that makes males
vulnerable to aza maybe there's
something there that makes males
vulnerable to the phenotype another
method is to look at endo phenotypes or
quantitative trait loci QTL so you know
even with gold standard diagnostic
instruments diagnosing autism is still
very very subjective so one thing that
genetics researchers have tried to do is
look at more quantitative traits so this
group looked at about 100 families did a
genome-wide linkage scan found a you
know pretty unimpressive LOD score on
chromosome 2 and then they took a subset
about half and these this subset all the
kids the affected kids had free speech
delay they repeated the linkage scan and
found that the LOD score more than
doubled on that same region so again
it's not seeing that there's a gene here
means that explains all of autism but
maybe it helps explain this particular
endo phenotype with just free speech
delay maybe has something to do with
language so that's one way that human
geneticist ride to get a handle on these
conflicting results from linkage studies
another method is called jiwa studies or
genome-wide Association studies so I
talked about how in linkage studies
there's a looking at pedigrees and
families in jiwa studies you basically
have two cohorts your patients with
autism and then another cohort of
typically-developing control individuals
and you're basically just asking the
question are there more mutations and
one than the other where are those
mutations etc so a group there were two
big studies published in 2009 one group
did this genome-wide Association study
had two big cohorts again of patients
and typically developing individuals and
had a bunch of snips representing the
entire genome and just looked to see are
there certain snips that are over
represented in the patients compared to
the control group and actually out of
all of that analysis they found one snip
on chromosome five the short arm of
chromosome five actually didn't even
land in a gene is landed between two
genes cut here and nine and could here
in ten so when they do this analysis
they come up with something called a
Manhattan plot cuz it looks like the the
Manhattan skyline punctuated by a
skyscrapers and so on the on the y axis
are the p-values and then these are the
chromosomes 1 through X and so they
found the highest signal on chromosome 5
and here's a diagram of chromosome 5
right in here and so the reason why this
was interesting is because get here and
9 and get here in 10 are involved in
neuronal cell adhesion so involved in
brain development
so this plausibly right could be as
involved in the pathogenesis of autism
but one of the themes of I think autism
genetics research is that it can be
quite low yield so you do a lot of
analysis look at big cohorts a lot of
snips across the genome and again they
landed on one that was statistically
significant another group the same year
published a report another jiwa study
and they also looked at snips across the
entire genome and
a different region happened to also be
on the short arm of chromosome 5 but
between again two genes rather than even
landing on a gene called semi 5a and a
taste receptor so maybe the taste
receptor not so important in autism but
the second 5a was very interesting
because this the product of this gene
the protein has been implicated in
axonal guidance so again in neural
development which could be plausibly
related to autism but you do notice that
they didn't replicate each other and
that's also the recurring theme in
autism I think I've already mentioned is
that a lot of these studies come up with
a different set of genes or locations
that seem to be important and I think
again this just speaks to the genetic
heterogeneity in the disorder so here's
another method that human geneticists
use to find as each genes set of genetic
analysis so basically this is looking
for chromosomal abnormalities so
balanced versus unbalanced balanced
chromosomal abnormalities are those in
which there's no net gain or loss of
genetic material but there's some
abnormalities so for example in an
inversion or a translocation here's an
example of a balanced translocation
where you have two chromosomes a and B
and for some reason again maybe
spontaneous inherited they've switched
ends here so even if no chromosomal
material has been lost or or gained
there's two break points that have been
left behind and these break points could
go right through a very important brain
express gene and completely disrupt that
gene so that's a balanced translocation
here's an example of an unbound
chromosomal abnormality and everyone's
pretty much familiar with this one Down
syndrome trisomy 21 where you have a
whole extra chromosome 21 so you have
net gain of chromosomal material and we
know that there are a lot of clinical
consequences to that so here's a
real-life example that came through our
laboratory here at Yale where we had a
patient with autism who had a
chromosomal abnormality so these are all
the chromosomes laid out organized and
this is chromosome 7 and their error
points to the abnormal chromosome 7
here's a blow-up of that image where you
have the normal 7 and then if you can
see there's a different staining pattern
to that chromosome and that's because
there is an inversion that's happened so
this piece here and here
there were breakpoints at these sites
and then the chromosomal material in
between flipped and reinserted so now
you have possibly disrupted genes left
behind so to figure that out we did use
the technique called fish or
fluorescence in situ hybridization so
what you're seeing here is a photograph
that was taken under the microscope of
this patient's chromosomes they were
dyed in blue and so they've been laid
out on a glass slide put out under a
microscope
take a photo and we've also used DNA
probes labeled in red that kind of stick
to where we think that breakpoint is
based on the karyotype and so we see
here this is the normal chromosome seven
and the reason why you t see two signals
is because this is a metaphase
chromosome where part of the cell cycle
where the chromosomes are condensed and
there's sister chromatids and then you
see the admiral chromosome seven here
where that red signal that's supposed to
spend that breakpoint has split because
of that inversion and because we know
now the sequence of the human genome we
can look exactly where that split
happened and see what is there any gene
that's been disrupted there and it
happens that in this patient a very
important gene that's functions at the
neural synapse has been split in half
and so our hypothesis is that this is
this patient in this family is the only
one who has a chromosomal abnormality of
this type and also is the only one who
has a diagnosis on the spectrum so maybe
those two are linked so the next step
would be to look at this gene and more
families and see how big is the
contribution of that gene so this is how
we go about identifying candidate genes
and trying to confirm them as really
being associated with autism so there
are also genome-wide cnv studies that
have been done so basically looking for
copy number variants duplications
deletions throughout the entire genome a
number of studies have been published on
this one group looked at a bunch of
patients with autism and found that copy
number variants were significantly
enriched in certain pathways so again
you see like a bunch of genes that have
been affected by duplications or
deletions often they're rare causes so
they might find one of these genes in
one family maybe a couple of families so
what they what this group did was take a
step back and say okay
well can we group these genes together
in some kind of common pathway that
would give us an idea about what you
know maybe neurotransmitter systems are
signaling pathways or some cell
processes are involved in autism so they
found that a bunch of their genes were
all neuronal cell adhesion molecules
another bunch were involved in the
ubiquitin pathway which is involved in
protein recycling another group
published genome-wide C&V study and
found that individuals with autism at a
higher rate of rare genic seen these in
other words seen bees that land on genes
because sometimes you might find a CMV
that doesn't land on a gene alliance
between two genes but so they seem to
have more deleterious possibly CNB's
individuals with autism compared to
typically developing controls and you
can see they come up with a different
list of genes all important brain
express genes but you know different
from the one above so that again tells
you about the genetic heterogeneity in
this disorder our group here at Yale
also published a genome-wide cnv study
and found that in simplex families
there's a higher rate of rare de novo
Sienna be so simplex families are those
in which there's only one affected child
and the thinking is that in these
families that the disorders due to de
novo mutations or spontaneous mutations
instead of something being inherited
from parents that would affect multiple
children and so comparing in individuals
with autism with their unaffected
siblings the individuals with autism did
have a higher rate of these rare de novo
C and B's and these are the regions that
we found you can see there's some
overlap we also landed on Erikson one
just like this group but this usually
seems to be the exception when two
groups land on the same gene so if these
are all rare causes of autism why is it
important like does it help us really
uncover the pathophysiology of the
disorder and I would say that even
though they are individually rare they
are important because they do implicate
gene networks since we have so little
understanding of where exactly may be or
when exactly in the brain the things are
going awry in autism this at least gives
us some clues to try to figure out the
pathophysiology of the disorder all
right so not one hot topic in the field
and in neuropsychiatric disorders in
general is looking for overlaps in
genetic etiology and so we know that
autism and schizophrenia are two very
different
but interestingly there's some common
genetics so here is a paper that mapped
out some of the cnvs that are
specifically found in autism those in
schizophrenia are in blue but then there
are regions throughout the genome in
which there are CNVs that appear in both
autism and schizophrenia for example
like right here on chromosome 15 and
they're here on chromosome 1 so why is
this important well this again might
shed light autism and schizophrenia
might shed light on each other
why do two different disorders have some
common genetic elements maybe there are
some common pathways that are affected
in both so another technique that looks
at across the entire genome is whole
exome sequencing this technique has
really revolutionized our work in human
genetics because it's really sped up our
work so there was a time like with that
patient I showed you at the chromosomal
abnormality in the fish experiment where
we looked at one patient at a time or
one family at a time maybe one gene at a
time and try to make an association with
autism but whole exome sequencing lets
us look at all the genes and there's
about 20,000 some genes in the human
genome we can look at them all at once
in every individual in one experiment
you can imagine how fast our experiments
go then so the purpose of whole exome
sequencing is to obtain the DNA sequence
for the entire coding region or the
exome of the genome so remember the
genome is dotted with genes but there
are intergenic regions in which there
are no known coding genes so this
represents 1% really just of the of the
human genome so the human genome is 3
billion base pairs and this is just 1%
of it but so here is for example a
section of the exome a reference
sequence and what you get from whole
exome sequencing are these short reads
of bases and you get millions in of
these reads and you try to line them up
which is a big by informatics challenge
to the reference genome and look to see
where you might see a mutation and so
you try to find mutations this way and
again the power of it is that you're
looking at all genes at once instead of
one gene at a time so this is the kind
of like a fancy glass slide with these
small channels in which you input the
patient's DNA and what happens here's a
of what's going on the chemical reaction
the power comes in effect that the DNA
the patient's DNA is sheared up into
chunks and then it's basically amplified
over and over again and that enables it
to be sequenced at a great enough depth
where you can find rare mutations so you
have hundreds of millions of these
molecular clusters where you have
amplified chunks of the patient's DNA
and it's all done in this machine that
really just sits on a bench top in the
web over in our West campus and is this
called a Illumina HiSeq machine and here
was our experimental design for whole
exome sequencing we studied 200 quartets
from the Simon simplex collection this
is a collection a very rigorously
phenotyped of families affected by
autism that are mostly simplex meaning
that there's only one affected child
actually they're all simplex and what
our hypothesis was so when I say quartet
I mean that you have a pedigree like
this a family structure a father a
mother in this example there are two
sons one affected by autism and one
whose typically developing and so
hypothesis is that there are more de
novo variants in patients compared to
their unaffected siblings which accounts
for their phenotype so when you do whole
exome sequencing you have about a 30
million base pair target as I said it's
about 1% of the genome and so whole
exome sequencing yields a hundred
million of those short reads each about
75 base pairs long and analysis is done
on a high performance cluster which you
can imagine is a lot of processing power
and so this is kind of what you get the
output so there are a number of steps
where you get the raw reads from the
West Campus from the Yale Center for
genome analysis so the raw sequencing
reads and then you go through many steps
algorithms to align the reads to the
reference genome and then look for
possible mutations and then try to
figure out which ones might be de novo
and then try to annotate the variants
meaning are the variants in a gene are
they in a brain express gene have they
changed a site that's pretty well
conserved through evolution which maybe
makes it more important so so for in
this one subject we got almost a hundred
million reads 98% of them aligned
correctly to
the reference genome and so we also have
a lot of other statistics involved like
mean coverage so each base we seen see
on average about 120 times and you have
to have a lot of depth to this because
if there's a very rare variant you might
not see it very often right so you need
a lot of depth the error rate is pretty
okay 1.5 percent so in this one person
from whole exome sequencing we got about
30,000 different variants throughout the
exome and so that's a lot of variance to
try to investigate and try to figure out
which one might be associated with the
phenotype of this of this patient so
then we try to filter in various ways
for example we might look at those
variants that are novel that no one has
ever reported before for example we
might again look for variants that are
just brain expressed or are conserved
positions etc so even when you do this
you still end up with a lot of variance
you have almost 800 novel variants in
this one person so again it's a big
bioinformatics challenge to do this type
of analysis but it's actually proven to
be quite high yield so here are the
results of our whole exome sequencing
experiment so we found just as we had
hypothesized that there are more brain
expressed protein changing de novo
mutations in patients compared to their
unaffected siblings now it's not that
the siblings didn't have any of these in
fact they had we found a 67 of these
types of what we would think deleterious
mutations in 200 unaffected siblings but
it happened that the patients had more
and significantly more with an odds
ratio of over 2 so this tells us that
these types of damaging mutations all we
think are damaging mutations are
enriched in patients with autism
compared to their unaffected siblings
and remember that the recurring theme I
said of like low yield so after all this
work really we landed on one gene called
SC into a that was where we where we had
a recurrent hit in other words we landed
on this gene and more than one family in
fact we landed on two families so two
families with each with a de novo
mutation and a brain expressed gene an
SE n to a it actually has been
associated previously with epilepsy but
these patients with autism in our group
didn't have epilepsy didn't have
seizures meaning that maybe these
mutations are not just associated with
epilepsy but they are actually
sated with autism and these families so
that's what we found but there were a
number of other groups who are also
doing whole exome sequencing on families
affected by autism so in a total of a
thousand families there were a handful
of genes went four or five others so
half a dozen altogether in which there
was more than one of these Dilla tereus
mutations occurring and since this is so
rare statistically speaking they seem to
be strongly associated with autism
because they are so rare and that when
we find them more than more than one
family we think that there's a strong
association there so again this gene
list is diverse so as you can see
throughout this whole talk so far that
there is no one gene causing autism as I
mentioned before there's not even a few
there seems to be many and people
estimate that there might be hundreds of
genes involved in autism so how do you
get a handle on this well before I get
to that I'll just to mention something
about CHD eight because the follow-up
studies after the exome studies have
shown that identified at least a few
more I think up to eight or nine now de
novo mutations in this one gene which is
an interesting gene because it regulates
transcription it regulates the
expression of other genes so sometimes
you might wonder well how can one
mutation and one gene cause a disorder
as complicated as autism
well this gene is one of these master
regulatory genes it affects the
expression how other genes are turned on
and off so you can imagine that it would
have diverse effects if it was mutated
and dysfunctional or non-functional in a
patient with autism so these are this is
the human chromosome displayed in this
black strand that's been packaged up by
proteins called histones and so see hd8
helps recruit or binds with other
proteins that these nucleosomes is what
they referred to as this package to
chromosomes and they affect the
expression or the transcription of these
genes how they're turned on and off so
so it's a very interesting candidate
gene that's become a people have become
very interested in in the autism
genetics field alright so here's a
diagram that I found actually from the
Emory genetics laboratory website which
really shows well the genetic
architecture of autism that there are
many different genes that seem to be
involved there's a chunk of
cases of autism which seem to be due to
common variants that in other words
variants that are not so rare that are
found in at least 1% of the general
population so maybe these genes
contribute a small amount of risk but
together they think they can create the
phenotype in a person there is also
single gene Mendelian forums especially
those that I showed you overlap with
genetic syndromes for example that are
associated with autism side of genetic
abnormalities that have been reported
for example the 15q duplication so any
and what I'm trying to get across here
is that there seems to be a lot of genes
involve many types of mutations involved
and so how do we get a handle on what
the common pathway might be well it's
going to be developmental neurobiology
that's going to help us figure this out
so there were two really great studies
one coming from Yale from the not
systems lab in which the human brain
transcriptome was analyzed and so what I
mean by that is that in this particular
paper this research group took I'm just
a couple of subjects post-mortem brain
tissue and looked at many many regions
numerous regions throughout the brain
and look to see which genes are being
turned on and off and are being
expressed in those brain regions I think
it was something like over a thousand
different regions or spots so in other
words these groups are trying to develop
an atlas of gene expression throughout
the brain so doctor systems group here
at Yale also did a similar experiment
although they looked at many brains they
looked at a handful of regions in each
one but they also had about a thousand
different samples so in there this is an
example of their results for a gene
called neural again for X which has been
associated with autism and the y-axis is
the signal intensity of how strongly
that gene is expressed in various
regions this on the x-axis is the age of
the post mortem brain tissue so they
span from like six weeks after a post
conceptual age all the way to 80 year
old brains so you looked at the entire
lifespan and found for example that
neural ligand for X is expressed very
strongly throughout the entire lifespan
this is considered strong expression so
when you have a map like this then what
you can do is you can take your list of
what you think are very important
genes and autism that I've seemed to
have a lot of evidence for association
and see and try to map out when are they
turned on and off in the brain
throughout the entire lifespan and this
is a review from Matt state and a nod
Destin looking at some of these strongly
associated genes genes strongly
associated with autism and looking to
see okay you know what is their level of
expression shown on the y-axis across
the lifetime and some of these seem to
travel together so when you have genes
that are co-expressed meaning they're
turned on or off at the same time and
certain regions of brain you think well
maybe they function together in some
common pathway and that gives us clues
as to the what the pathophysiology is of
the disorder so here's a very simplified
diagram of a nerve so some of these
genes like CH d8 that I mentioned before
are functioning in the central part of
the body of the neuron some are out here
in the neural synapses here's a get a
simplified diagram of a synapse and
showing that a bunch of these genes that
have been associated with autism
function at the synapse which is the
fundamental functional unit of the
nervous system so it makes sense that
there it would be a site of dysfunction
right and autism so you're going from
you know a long list of diverse genes to
figuring out okay where are they being
expressed and how could they be causing
the disorder and expression studies like
this really help us in that way here is
a diagram for a gene Co expression
analysis again done in Matt's lab here
at Yale where Jeremy wills II took a
bunch of autism associated genes from
the exome
studies and then also took this
transcriptome analysis done by not
systems lab and do something called a co
expression network analysis so look to
see are these genes again correlated in
terms of their expression
are they being turned on and off at the
same times in the same regions so
building this kind of co-expression
network where these seed genes are
autism associated genes and looking to
see what's coax breast with them try to
implicate other genes in autism and so
amazingly this diverse gene list
actually converges in certain specific
parts of the brain and at specific time
periods which tells us okay well this is
maybe when and where things go awry and
causing autism so it turns out that the
Jeanne's converge in mid fetal
development
and that it's in the prefrontal and
primary motor somatosensory cortex and
not only that but specifically in layer
five and six of the cortex and
glutamatergic projection neurons so here
this is really a great study that went
from a bunch of genes to like when and
where in the brain this might be these
genes might be acting and where
mutations in these genes might be having
an effect okay so I've been talking
about whole exome sequencing that is
really you know as I said revolutionize
accelerated our work but whole genome
sequencing is definitely here I'm it's
still about three to four times more
expensive than whole exome sequencing
but the price gets cheaper every day and
so there will come a point where instead
of just looking at the exome the protein
coding region in each patient we can
look at the entire genome and we know
from recent encode studies that about
something like 80% of intragenic regions
are also transcribed they might not be
genes but they're rnase of various sorts
that have various functions so this is a
picture of the ion proton whole genome
sequencing machine that also sits right
on a bench top I think there's one of
these in our west campus as well that
ours being piloted and so this is the
fancy looking glass slide in which you
input in the patient's DNA and then the
entire genome is sequenced and so again
you imagine the big bioinformatics
challenge that is it's it's it's
challenging enough to look at the exon
but the whole genome now you have a
hundred times as much information I like
showing this slide this is the cost per
human genome through years so way back
in 2001 it cost a hundred million
dollars to sequence to do genome
sequencing in one person this was the
human genome project and it took how
many years over ten years something like
that and then if you compare the cost
per human genome over the years you see
how much it's dropped so this is Moore's
law which you might be familiar with it
talks about a computer you know
computing power doubling about every 18
months or two years and so any
technology that's beating Moore's law is
really advancing quite rapidly so the
human genome now well at least in 2012
was less than $10,000 per human genome
so you can see how it dropped
steep that decline has been and I've
heard of genomes as little as $3,000 now
to get an entire genome sequenced in a
person so and actually there are a few
studies not that I looked at whole
genome sequencing in autism so looking
at all the bases not just the EXO so one
group a couple of years ago looked at
ten concordant monozygotic twins and
their parents and our conclusion was
that there are some hotspots for de novo
mutations in autism another group looked
at 32 families found de novo mutations
and about 20% of them inherited
mutations and about a third of them and
also came up with a candidate gene list
some of which you might be familiar with
like the Nexen one you saw that before
Sdn 2a we found with the exome
sequencing so now we're beginning to
land on the same gene more than once in
some of these studies and then found
some novel genes as well
another group looked at ten members of
just one family including two affected
individuals and found that the two
affected Pro bands shared mutations in a
gene called AG 3 so that was also
interesting so you'll see more and more
of these whole genome sequencing studies
as time goes on alright so just switch
gears a little bit from the research
field to clinical genetics evaluation
because the common question I get from
clinicians is all right so I have a
family affected by autism I have a child
how do I evaluate them in terms of
genetics and this is a hot topic like
what are the appropriate tests to do so
it's clear though that clinical genetics
evaluation will become increasingly
routine in the medical assessment of
autism and so another thing that a
clinician is often asked is well should
I only get clinical genetics testing
done and kids who are severely affected
because I'm more likely to find
something and so one group awhile back
now try to address this question by
looking at kids with classical autism
versus a milder form of autism pdd-nos
back in back then and then found about
similar rates even though there's a
small study the point here was that
everyone on the spectrum deserves
clinical genetic testing not those who
are just the most severely affected so
the American College of medical genetics
has put out some practice parameters for
how this genetics evaluation should look
needless to say there should be a well
doctor
family history pedigree analysis at
least of three generations because that
can help you look to see is there
something being inherited being passed
down in an autosomal dominant fashion or
recessive fashion or maybe in an
x-linked fashion it's important to
identify known syndromes like fragile X
or tuber sclerosis or others because
some of these other genetic syndromes
cannot have other organ involvement so
you don't want to miss that so
examination with special attention to
dismorphism
because these genetic syndromes are
often have very specific to some
morphisms associated with them if the
specific syndrome is suspected and to do
targeted testing for that particular
syndrome like Angelman syndrome for
example there is testing for that and
then if clinical indicators are present
then you do metabolic or mitochondrial
testing as well so another
recommendation from the group is to do
chromosomal microarray analysis or CMA
analysis this is basically looking for
copy number variants C and B's for
duplications or deletions across the
genome and then also testing for fragile
X because there is a significant overlap
between fragile x and autism routinely
in males I'm in this excellent disorder
and then in females of indicators are
presents example if there's positive
family history or our phenotypes so this
group in their paper projected some
diagnostic yields for various clinical
genetics experiments excuse me
evaluations and found that for
chromosomal microarrays again looking
for cnvs at about 10 percent of the time
they're positive and so this is
important to know again it might not
help exactly that particular individual
in terms of their treatment but it might
be very important for genetic counseling
purposes if those parents are thinking
about having other children or if there
are uncles and aunts who are worried
about their own children you know I
think if there's something being passed
around in a family for fragile X testing
is about one to five percent of the time
it's positive MEC p2 is a gene
associated with Rett syndrome but also
cases of autism zuv about four percent
of females turn out to be positive for
mutations in this gene p10 is involved
in over world syndromes this gene and
five percent of time it appears to be
mutated especially in those kids that
ever had circumference that's that's
large
karyotypes so looking for chromosomal
abnormalities
and a correct karyotype is 3 3% of time
that's positive so this group estimates
that you can identify some type of
genetic abnormality etiology in about 30
to 40 percent of individuals and so
strongly recommends that all of these
individuals get some type of clinical
should get their own clinical genetics
evaluation here is an example I found on
the web of a commercial autism gene
panel these have become very popular so
this is just one example I there are
many examples on the web and so what
these companies are advertising are
these autism gene panels so testing for
a bunch of genes that have been
associated with autism and often they're
directed to parents who already have a
child with autism and they're worried
about a younger child so I just want to
I think our goal in the future we hope
as human geneticist that we will have
such an autism gene panel that will
accurately predict risk for autism in an
individual who it's not yet has been
diagnosed but we just have to be very
cautious because these lists of genes
some of them have weak association with
autism or some of them are very rare
causes of autism so even if you if you
have a child with a mutation in one of
these genes and one of these commercial
autism gene panels it's not always easy
to interpret what that mutation might
mean so we just have to proceed
cautiously with these commercial gene
panels alright so another very important
question I get from especially parents
is asking well why you know how does it
help my child to figure out what gene
might be involved
is it gonna change management is it
gonna change treatment is it worth
spending all these resources and trying
to find the genes for autism and I would
argue that yes it is really important
I'm a bit biased obviously but I'm gonna
give you some examples of why it's so
important to find the genetic etiology
of a disorder so genes can really help
us understand the pathophysiology the
disease mechanism and that can really
help us try to design treatments so
here's one example Rhett syndrome which
is caused by most cases are caused by
mutations in a specific gene called a
MEK p2 so mutations it might be to cause
about 98
cases it controls the expression of
other genes so it's like that ch d8
we're addicts it it regulates the
expression of a lot of other genes so
patients with Rett syndrome show
abnormal neurons but not in a Ronal
death so the big question here is
conveyor but defective neurons be
repaired so a research group developed a
mutant mice mouse model lacking the MEK
p2 gene and these mice developed
neurological symptoms reminiscent of
what you find in patients with a Rhett
syndrome what they did next was they
genetically reactivated the MEK be two
gene and I did this an adult mutant mice
so not in pups not in utero but in adult
mice and they were able to reverse some
symptoms including deficits in neuronal
signaling in the hippocampus which has
been associated with autism so the big
takeaway here is that absence of this
gene doesn't irreversibly damaged
neurons and that you can do some
reversal of symptoms even an adult mice
so the thinking always as well is there
any hope after a child is born and is
you know can we intervene in any way and
so obviously this is many steps removed
from you know human treatment but the
point here the the what they were trying
to show is that even an adult mice that
they were able to reverse some symptoms
and that there's a lot more plasticity
in the brain than we then we suspect
even in later ages here's another
example fragile X syndrome and fmr1 so I
mentioned before I believe that loss of
fmr1 causes fragile X it also controls
the expression of other genes like MEK P
2 the pathophysiology of this disorder
involves hyperactivity of the glutamate
receptor and glue r5 in the brain so a
research group created mutant mice that
lacked the gene and they develop
neurological symptoms just like the
human patients and they found that by
reducing expression of this hyperactive
glutamate receptor by just half they
were able to show rescue of symptoms
including alterations in dendritic
density on neural cells and hippocampal
protein synthesis so and they've another
group found that the GABA agonist are
baclofen which is a pharmaceutical agent
corrects increased in optic protein
synthesis and spine density in these
mutant oh no actually you know
yeah and mutant my site
so again we we have gone from mutations
in a very specific gene called fmr1 to
try and to some insights into the
pathophysiology of fragile X and then to
developing treatments and here's my last
example of tuber sclerosis and TSC so
mutations in the tsc1 and TSE 2 genes
caused tuberous sclerosis the
pathophysiology of this disorder
involves a signaling pathway in
hippocampus called mTOR pathway or
mammalian target of rapamycin pathway so
mutant mice lacking one copy of TSE to
show cognitive deficits and treating
again adult mice with rapamycin improves
synaptic plasticity and behavioral
deficits another group looked at mutant
mice lacking one or two copies of tsc1
in the cerebellum these mice show
decreased neuronal activity abnormal
social interaction and repetitive
behavior and then treating with
rapamycin so targeting this signaling
pathway prevented pathological and
behavioral deficits so again a great
example of going from genes to
pathophysiology to to a very specific
treatments alright so here are some
future directions for the field I think
most people would agree and I feel that
it's very important to increase our
study population so most of the studies
that I was talking to you about had at
the most about a thousand families 1,500
families which sounds like a lot but if
you look at other complex disorders like
for example blood pressure studies heart
disease studies those those studies
include tens of thousands of patients
and maybe we haven't come up with the
entire genetic etiology of autism yet
haven't figured it out because we just
are not looking at enough patients at
each one of these studies so I think
that's very important that we increased
study populations by tenfold at least
and then I mentioned whole genome
sequencing so it's important to look at
the protein coding regions but it really
is also important to look at regulatory
elements those intergenic regions
promoters other areas that are involved
in gene expression looking at
mitochondrial sequences because there
might be associations between metabolic
and mitochondrial defects and autism
doing pathway analysis so this is talks
- this speaks to
having a diverse list of genes and then
trying to figure out other some common
pathways where they converge to produce
the phenotype I didn't mention much
about epigenetics but so epigenetics is
the chemical modification of the DNA
sequence so these are might also be
associated with disorders like autism
but the challenge would that be genetics
is that it's very tissue specific and
it's hard for us to go around getting
brain biopsies from our patients but
it's a field that we will have to try to
you know address and some people have
been trying to address in autism I'm
looking at biomarkers is a very hot
topic so taking results from neuron
imaging studies eye tracking experiments
ERPs and these are all being done here
at Yale which is why makes it a great
and rich area for research at yellow on
autism and looking to see well if we can
stratify our patients with some of these
more quantitative markers then maybe we
can find a common genetic mechanism in
those patients looking for the genetic
overlap between neuropsychiatric
nurseries I showed one quick example of
schizophrenia and autism and how they
might shed light on each other and then
really what's so important is doing a
functional analysis of variance so this
means bridging the genetics and the
neuroscience so so we might have a list
of genes might have a list of mutations
that seem to be strongly associated with
autism but we really need to do the
follow-up work so looking to see well
are these particular mutations really
causing damage to the structure and
function of a protein so doing in vitro
in vivo studies for example in cell
culture in mice doing post-mortem brain
tissue work a really hot topic in our
field is something called induced
pluripotent stem cells so as I mentioned
it's not possible to go around getting
brain biopsies from her patients and
we've been limited to looking at for
example blood cells because they're easy
to obtain relatively easy to obtain from
our families looking to see well you
know is there anything wrong with gene
expression in blood cells for example
and that's not a the best proxy right
for the brain so this technique involves
taking blood cells reprogramming them
into immature into pluripotent stem
cells and then reprogramming them into
neural cells so now you have this in a
dish where it might not be cells neural
cells from the brain of a patient but
you've taken their blood cells and kind
of trans
form them into neurons and then you can
study the neurons and see what's going
on is there anything going awry in the
neurons I have a couple of slides
showing how there are different types of
stem cells including embryonic stem
cells and these IPSC cells which involve
taking body cells like fibroblasts or
blood cells and reprogramming them with
chemicals to turn them into an immature
state and then there are naturally
occurring stem cells in the body from
various organs but the point is that
these kinds of stem cells can be
transformed into any type of tissue and
so our interest would be taking these
IPSC induced pluripotent stem cells and
transferring them into neural cells and
looking to see what's wrong maybe
perhaps with these neural cells so we
can create stem cell models of autism so
taking these iPS cells turning them into
neurons and just looking again an
addition of an in vitro disease model
and then maybe someday even down the
road we can do drug and screening maybe
toxicology testing and drug development
that's you know a bit far off but that's
the hope by going this route so that's a
really hot topic in the field the next
step after finding genes and mutations
is to really study those mutations in
depth and see how they might be bringing
about autism great so thank you for your
attention and I'll take any questions